welcome back I've missed you I even tore
my clothes and wore burlap in morning
[Music]
glad to have you here so folks a little
update I will be doing videos every
Thursday once again and now I know you
see right now this video isn't quite HD
but don't worry that's coming I'm
getting an HD cam or we're gonna do
these things we're gonna do them right
special thanks to National Center they
helped create these videos they've been
very supportive and I encourage you to
go check out the website now I'll be
doing these every week I'll be
interacting with you guys talking about
the news it's in the week and then once
every few weeks when I can get a little
bit of time away from fox news I'll be
going out and doing super videos on
locations with interviews and all that
jazz look for right now let's talk about
what's in the news this week Christine
O'Donnell caught a lot of flack in the
mainstream media for asking where the
words separation of church and state
appear in the Constitution specifically
the First Amendment now I am not
endorsing Christine O'Donnell so before
anyone comes out here and tries to send
me your political candidates to endorse
stop what I do find interesting is that
in this case Christine O'Donnell was
right
that didn't stop everybody from laughing
at her separation of church and state of
course it's in the Constitution stupid
she's she's stupid right not in this
case the words the buzzwords separation
of church and state were taken from a
private letter that Thomas Jefferson
wrote to the Danbury Baptists trying to
ease their worries expressing their
Rubino state denomination I know I've
talked about this before on this channel
it's just amazing how many people get
that wrong when it comes down to this
debate be sure to always have your
constitution give it to the person with
whom you're conversing and ask them to
find the word separation of church and
state in the Constitution give them all
the time they need Oh in other news Bono
sucks
in other news Joy Behar said about
Sharron Angle and you might want to ever
kids leave the room here
that's enough time that the [ __ ] is
going to hell I know she should have
said the skank is going to Hades this is
just the kind of crap that's acceptable
from people like Joy Behar if a
conservative says this they're angry
they're an old windbag and they hate
Blacks and Jews when Joy Behar says it
it's cute because she's dumb you could
literally be sitting across the table
from Joy Behar talking to her and not
even be having the same conversation
well you know I just think this dead is
out of control I think the spending is
unprecedented I think we're passing it
down to generations I know like my
ex-husband never used to wash his feet
no no that's that's that's not what I'm
saying I'm just talking about this
government that's ballooning out of
control to a level that we haven't
really seen before and right I love
blueberry pancakes
do you need counseling before I close us
out I want to know what do you folks
want to hear about what are the hot
topics in the news and what would you
like to see for the next super video I
must go but follow me on Twitter for my
fox news appearances that I do every
week and I will see you next Thursday
[Music]
you
[Music]